called e walker ghost turned wolf is the
main antagonist in Ghost Recon break
point in this video we'll be talking
about the series of events that led to
this proud us warrior turning his back
on his country and his ghost brothers at
this time the game has only been out for
a week or two so there's still a lot of
Intel and collecting but more
importantly this video will contain some
spoilers so if you'd like to enjoy the
story at your own pace I urge you to
switch off this video now
[Music]
[Music]
you
Walker came from a military family in
fact he was fourth generation army after
graduating at the top of his class he
was groomed and fast-tracked into
Strategic Command career for field
operations
Walker was quickly hit hunted for the
first Special Forces Operational
Detachment otherwise known as Delta
Force but was eventually recruited by
the elite special mission unit known as
the ghosts from the beginning
young Walker's career was as straight as
an arrow his unwavering faith in the
mission and his intense desire for
results often led him right into the
heart of the battle where he was in his
element fighting for his country and
family he was part of the need-to-know
rip team which was assigned to
borderline retaliation operations
against dirty targets and a US or
American ally protection however he was
also deployed to more standard
operations worldwide as a ghost team
leader in fact this is where Nomad first
met Walker this is the hard part of
Bolivia eat my [ __ ] well you must be
Nomad Walker did uh did you or not go
through part of selection together
no it's jump school I was in the chalk
next to yours that's right with that uh
due from pararescue right first recon
guys fun times man now I got a got some
more fun for you
here's your briefing say you uh you want
some candy hey excuse me
we haven't even started this mission
commands already talking about sending
us back to the Middle East again and
that's one that never ends it's because
the Wars easier in peace company man
back there you never saw by the way yeah
he believes this fantasies called
Wonderland people never fight it's all
rainbows and marshmallows and unicorns
and [ __ ] I guess we could talk about
that another time no say no man it's
good to see you too man you say healthy
always the next homie MIT Walker would
be later on during Operation Kingslayer
in Bolivia I've already covered this in
a previous video so feel free to skip
the section but this is quite an
integral part of the story where Walker
begins to question the motives of
superiors during Operation Kingslayer
the ghosts were called in by CIA contact
Bowman to extract a skel tech research
and development technical director
Daniel who had been arrested by unis
dead
Daniel had knowledge of sensitive u.s.
industrial secrets that needed to be
protected at all costs eventually after
hunting him down
they found that fellow ghost team leader
major Col Dee Walker had arrived there
first but he was working under his own
agenda Walker had found out that Daniel
was the one who designed an advanced
surveillance drone for unidad they had
then weaponized it and used it to kill
two of Walker's team the Walker agreed
to help the ghost extract Daniel so he
could meet up with Berman the curious as
to why Bowman was keeping him alive he
stayed close by to investigate later it
was found out that Daniel had handed
Bowman over to unidad and after Walker
interrogated him Daniel was killed
Walker and the other ghosts rescued
Berman but there were some questions
that needed to be answered Bowman had to
face Walker's accusations and explained
that she was just following orders from
his superiors Daniel had been a key
unidad Informer and that she had to
protect him in order to secure multiple
US interests in Bolivia it's all about
it's about you helping to steal
information from the government giving
it to unidad I didn't steal anything I
was helping a spy an enemy spy now hold
on my orders were to protect him for the
success of multiple US interests in
Bolivia and the Bolivian people spoken
like a true traitor whatever happened to
loyalty to country you should have
killed that engineer the second you knew
he turned if you could protect a man
like that what's to keep you from
selling information yourself [ __ ] you I
had orders and I was following them
orders orders you orders got my men
killed
they ain't an enemy I'll take your
orders ease up up your ass Walker now
this [ __ ] gets dirty we all get paid to
root around of the scum now we come out
of that muck as clean as we can
listen no I said I'm on
look I'm sorry for the loss of your men
really now I might strut around like I'm
the [ __ ] of the walk but I don't call
the shots
I follow orders [ __ ] you had command
on the ground you call the shots every
time you obey an order listen you've
been out there this is an impossible
situation at least Bowman gives a [ __ ]
you trust that spook you gotta trust
somebody Walker yeah okay not used to
trust you and for now I'll just her you
keep your nose clean moment you owe me
for the lives of two of my men you
straight what I order this Saturday I'll
come and I will collect on that dead
[Music]
February 2022 Walker along with several
ghosts were deployed in the Middle East
to run counterterrorism operations
Delvon been at this for days you gotta
keep talking to them are you gonna do
something yeah well waterboarding
doesn't work so I don't know what else
to do you don't know what to do and what
the hell man let him be british ins is
illegal
[Music]
Xabi gorgeous divider you call Pandora's
box please water up this is Tandy
you know you know we can't be doing that
[ __ ] chrissake
you wanna split hairs over what's legal
what's not [ __ ] this ain't nothing
compared to what would happen if we
handed him off to a real contractor well
used to work with this badass
blond-haired [ __ ] from South Africa
she loved torture took pleasure out of
it but let me tell you something she got
answered no no that was a confession you
could count on god damn daddy's boy gon
take his instructions out of his FN
playing office politics you really want
to work with a shitbird like that would
you rather have a competent contractor
in your corner yeah well not a bad days
work I'll have my medium-rare
oops it's your problem
you guys are tasked to me you're my
thugs with guns it'll be real clear with
you Vaughn we're here to babysit you we
don't answer to you he just stay out of
our way we'll roll you over it was
beginning to get too much for Walker
with no incoming support and watching
his brothers getting gunned down around
him he felt trapped and alone he started
questioning who and what he was fighting
for what did you do there was uh I
thought someone was gonna shoot me this
is our village Vaughn
these are [ __ ] allies she had a
weapon and she had a gun Wow see no
[ __ ] gun no she had a weapon see
she left me no choice you gotta be
kidding me
you're done you have wasted too much of
my [ __ ] time as it is no you can't do
this to me you did this to you no this
is your fault you kept riding me pushing
me you don't you don't oh man my dad is
gonna hear what you did to me you
[ __ ] worm you cried of your daddy
that what you're gonna do every single
time you [ __ ] up you put the blame on
someone else don't you any time you're
in trouble
you just wait for that daddy of yours to
swoop on in huh let me tell you
something your daddy he ain't here
[ __ ] you I'm a good soldier I'm a good
soldier you are a worthless [ __ ]
human being Hey
come on my bun give me your weapon
come on look
[Music]
I've had enough
what the hell did you do he was done
well now he's done
says
I didn't kill that worthless poke old
village you might have come after us
it is a bright water the man Walker shot
was the son of a u.s. senator
[Music]
what the hell cold a kid had friends in
high places we're here to make the world
a better place we're here to get a
promotion
I always thought you're a little
unbridled you're just an [ __ ] sir the
lieutenant was out of control he was
mentally unstable a danger to us into
the inside give me that [ __ ] nomad if
lieutenant von Hutten killed that
civilian the pair of you would be
rotting in a hole in Leavenworth oh you
always knew he was [ __ ] useless
everybody complain about his shitty war
goddamn sense of entitlement
you can't kill someone just because he's
bad at his job we are here to complete a
task sir would you sacrifice our mission
would you risk our lives just cuz that
kids daddy is a senator you're a lying
Walker
are you gonna do sir
you gonna charge me you know something
it'd be worth it
this here's about what's right what's
right murdering an officer the United
States Army is right
what's right is getting any company in
counterintelligence officer off the
goddamn battlefield oh [ __ ] what's right
is protecting our mission from a
privilege breath [ __ ] our [ __ ] up worse
than the enemy does colonel you cannot
lie standing up for something boss a man
with no balls no vision Walker
ease up you listen to your friend
colonel your ghosts but you're not
untouchable okay Stan this [ __ ] anymore
[ __ ] we doing working for these [ __ ]
they don't care how hard we work they
got no [ __ ] idea about what it is we
do listen I stay because we do try to do
what's right Claire no this chain of
command god damn sanctimonious bastards
you are a plague on this earth you wanna
do us right well you can't not here are
you quite finished
yeah I think I am
enough was enough from political
protection of traitors where two of his
men killed two being abandoned and
ignored by officers behind desks in
times of war and finally witnessing the
sons of Senators not being held
accountable for their actions
he believes mankind has lost its way and
the upper classes have privileged need
to be brought in line gathering support
from several fellow ghosts Walker went
rogue and launched an attack killing
former brothers and even one of the
senior ghosts command in 2016
Jace Kell had completed the construction
of the new scale technology headquarters
on aroa and island in the South Pacific
Ocean through his vision was to become
the hub for the development and
production of drone and artificial
intelligence technology by 2024 aroer
was home to more than 30,000 residents
and internal security had become a
requirement so a private military
company named Sentinel was hired
eventually Walker came on board as Jay
scales military advisor as he'd begun to
take an interest in skeltox advanced
military technology however it wasn't
long before Walker and his wolves rally
together with Sentinel and took control
of her own all communications to and
from Aurora was shut down using Jay
scales cutting-edge technology Walker
track down the people who were
responsible for the death of his men
back in Bolivia he then used the
state-of-the-art drones from scale to to
assassinate political candidate
responsible for the murders around this
time
these were the actions that triggered
Operation green stone we're 32 ghosts
were flown in by helicopter to
investigate the island but as we all
know the majority of these ghosts
wouldn't even step foot on a row the
same drone swamps that Walker was using
to keep the residents from escaping was
also stopping anyone from entering the
island from Walker's journal entries
it's clear that he plans to use skel
tech drones as a solution to what he
describes as a nation under God forsaken
fools liberated by lies justified by
complacency that the moral high ground
it was built upon has already begun to
erode there are certain parts of this
video where deliberately avoided and
instead have followed the story as it's
been presented to us in the game and
reality there are a large number of
events in between that have driven
Walker to some of these actions I want
to State I'm not intending to be
misleading as such but I am trying to
keep the spoilers to a minimum this
early on in the piece plus I'd like some
more time to go over something Intel
properly and click the pieces of still
missing don't worry though I will be
covering at all there's a lot of juicy
stuff that keeps popping up every day
actually a lot more than I was initially
expecting anyway I hope you're enjoying
the game as much as I am thank you very
much for watching the video and I'll
catch you in the next one Cheers
[Music]
you